hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong and i'm
alongside my second favorite comedian
mr mark ellis okay but only for this
time frame i'm putting uh your pal
zielinski as my favorite comedian since
the leader of ukraine was a former
comedian that's all i will say he's just
my favorite comedian at this time he
used to see him at the open mics we'd
fist bump the you know good times all
around but uh much support to uh to the
people of ukraine i um i mean
this is why we do this show jack and at
least this is why you do this show is
because i know where your heart really
is and it lies in awards season and now
we finally have the show that you didn't
have to prepare for it all that i had to
scramble around and watch six movies in
the last two days to gear up for and
that would be it's our oscars show yeah
it's our oscars particularly best
picture we're talking about all the best
pictures what should when what shouldn't
even be nominated where the tomato meter
rotten tomatoes got some of these wrong
in my humble opinion so this is going to
be a fun episode and then you and our
esteemed guests get to correct me when i
um overstep my bounds stumping for
godzilla versus kong yes we're gonna run
down all the scores but before that we
obviously have to introduce our guest
for this episode he's a friend of mine
kyle buchanan the pop culture reporter
for the new york times and the writer of
the projectionist column he has a new
book out that we are going to talk in
depth with him about but before we get
to that let's go ahead and find out what
folks are saying about our 10 best
picture nominees in two minutes with tim
[Music]
alright so here are the scores for all
the best picture winners in alphabetical
order and just a reminder these are not
based on adjusted scores these are
strictly what we have right now belfast
is certified fresh at 87 on the tomato
meter with 293 reviews coda is certified
fresh at 96 on the tomato meter with 256
reviews don't look up is rotten at 56
with 281 reviews incidentally don't look
up is the worst reviewed best picture
nominee since extremely loud and
incredibly close from 2012 which was
rotten at 45
drive my car is certified fresh at 98
with 163 reviews
dune is certified fresh at 83 with 465
reviews
king richard is certified fresh at 90
with 268 reviews licorice pizza is
certified fresh at 91 with 273 reviews
nightmare alley is certified fresh at 79
with 313 reviews the power of the dog is
certified fresh at 93 with 321 reviews
and finally last but not least west side
story is certified fresh at 93 with 348
reviews last year's best picture winner
nomad land is certified fresh at 93 with
421 reviews and the best reviewed best
picture of all time is it happened one
night which is certified fresh at 99
with 103 reviews we covered that one on
a previous podcast so those are your
nominees i'm hearing the wrap it up
music right now so i just want to thank
lucy and jacqueline and mark for
everything i couldn't have done it
without you and thank you so much back
to you folks
and it happened one night reference oh
we were so young when that movie came
out jacqueline yes honestly uh that best
picture uh chat that we did with eric
cohn was incredible but i have to say i
do think our chat with kyle is going to
top that so let's go ahead and cue that
up now in our movie talk section
all right everyone please welcome now to
the rotten tomatoes podcast mr kyle
buchanan the pop culture reporter for
the new york times and writer of the
projectionist column he has a new book
out blood sweat and chrome the wild and
true ride of mad rex of mad max fury
road and he also happens to be a man
with an
impeccable suit game i've seen it ladies
and gentlemen you do not even no
kyle sir how are you doing i'm good you
know i mean listen i'm i'm a southern
california
guy i wear t-shirt and shorts almost all
the time but when required to step it up
and wear a suit which you know is part
of my job going to these award shows i
will wear a suit i will turn it out and
they will be cool suits yeah see they
will be cool jaclyn i mean look is is
that people look at me probably the same
way some might look at kyle they're like
oh well look at how relaxed and chill
that guy is what we're doing is we're
conserving our energy for the next time
that we have to suit up so we're not
like you know i i that's why i couldn't
be like the president of the united
states for example that many other
reasons but like i can't do a suit every
day but i can pull it off like once a
month mark though before we get into our
discussion today because we're both kyle
and i live in the award space um when
i'm not on this podcast trust ladies and
gentlemen that is what mistress has sort
of uh kidnapped me uh we need to break
down our 10 best picture nominees and
sort of rank them and you have our
framework for this correct yes i do i
have the ranking formula and i am ready
to go with it so i'm going to give you
the ranking formula order so starting at
the top and then i'm also going to give
you all the tomato meter because that is
how prepared i am thanks to the notes
put together by producing lucy without
which i would be lost so here we go in
order of our ranking formula rotten
tomatoes and that that kind of factors
in like how many reviews there are for a
particular film that sort of stuff so
here we go with the power of the dog
shout out to molly the wonder dog 93
certified fresh followed by coda which
is 95 certified fresh
west side story coming into the three
spot 92 percent certified fresh they're
all certified fresh at this point drive
my car is number four at 98
licorice pizza somehow it's better than
do i don't get it 91
dune is right behind licorice pizza 83
on the tomato meter king richard gets us
back into the a territory with 90
percent number eight is belfast 87
percent nightmare alley is 79
and
bringing up the rear is a movie that it
really is encouraging its cast to not do
what it's doing to all these other
award-contending movies don't look up
and that is 56
the only rotten film according to the
tomato meter nominated for best picture
so there you go
ranking score i will say for anyone
that's sort of like curious about why we
do that the reason being is a film like
drive my car which is 98
certified fresh and i think numerically
the highest ranked best picture
actually got a fraction of the reviews
of a film like power of the dog who had
over 300 reviews because it was a very
widely reviewed film at 93. so the idea
to be we want to re reward the most
populous films that were judged by the
largest version of the critical
community because then you'd have a
bunch of films that just had five
reviews and positive reviews be at the
top of all of our lists and i don't
think that's fair drive my car is
incredible but i don't think you can
compare how many critics commented on
that to
power of the dog i'm curious kyle what
you think of this whole thing well
although in some ways drive my car is
the critic success story of awards
season i mean it's really crazy
um i'm i'm thinking about how drive my
car was nominated for all the categories
that parasite won but parasite for as
unlikely as that was a best picture
winner you know had also won the palm to
or can it kind of was anointed as soon
as it debuted that wasn't the case with
driving my car i mean i was at that
canned film festival drive my car didn't
win first place second place or third
place
you got a screenplay award hey not so
bad but still
people did not leave that festival
thinking this is going to be the oscar
movie and it only became that because
those critics groups the new york film
critics the los angeles film critics and
the national society film critics all
really threw their muscle behind it and
said this is the best film of the year
they really did and i actually saw him
the other night so i'm going to go ahead
and shout him out on this although he'll
never listen to it um justin chang who
is a member of i believe two of those
organizations
and national society yeah and a ranking
one i put his foot right on the pedal of
any gas that that film gets i think
janice films should take the man out to
a five-star dinner because he wrote so
eloquently on the films but i also think
internally and his organizations help
champion
their its worthiness to other folks so
you know the the academy is becoming
more international we're seeing more
films not in the english language make
the best picture race but it's really
impressive that this movie
made it over honestly a lot of academy
darlings like almodovars parallel
mothers asgar farhati's a hero palo
sorrentino's the hand of god these are
all people who have been recognized by
oscar before these are their favorites
these are people that the academy knows
and they still went for hamakuchi that
really shows you the power of critics
absolutely i'm like in mud this this
just so like i love it i was about to
ask you mark what about you what do you
think about this list i know you just
literally got like it's like sometimes
when i listen to mark and other
comedians talk about comedy or football
like i know i'm there but i also know
i'm like
yeah
not
mean this is this is how it goes when i
get to be jacqueline's plus one at one
of these uh fancy events where she's
hobnobbing and i'm just kind of on the
outer circle you know like i'm that guy
at the party that has to try to time the
laugh with everyone else so it feels
like i'm in the conversation but with
this i i guess
my question before i get to like the
order and how i feel about it is has it
gotten easier or harder to predict
what's going to win at the oscars based
on other award shows
like in the last decade because isn't
there always like some award show that
is like the barometer like whether it's
critics choice or uh or sag awards or
something like that or has it gotten
tougher to nail down what is going to
take the top honors at the oscars this
year is particularly tough because we
did not have a golden globes we did not
have that televised hit that happened in
january that kind of laid out who the
front runners are yeah uh
with the ccas you also have the cc
critics choice awards had tried to uh
kind of usurp the golden globes uh date
but because of omicron they had to delay
so it's kind of the wilderness but
that's exciting to me i i think that the
sag awards could clarify things somewhat
although there is a notable non-overlap
between the nominees uh for sag and the
nominees for the oscars this year i
think a really kind of exciting
provocative non-overlap a lot of people
nominate for oscars that were not in sag
and vice versa so i i don't know i hope
that it's going to be really suspenseful
until the end
i think it actually will um the only
thing i will add is mark uh you skipped
the easy questions and literally went to
like the most difficult question that is
in our industry right now it's like me
coming in
first before there's even a ball place
like who do you think's gonna win the
super bowl easy bro
sometimes it is easy sometimes it's so
boring and true you know maybe maybe in
two and a half weeks we'll think that
but uh right now it feels excitingly
wide open you look at this list
that we ran down and so there's a few
that movies that i thought could have
been on there maybe instead of a
nightmare alley or don't look up like i
would have tossed i'm a big animal fan
i'm not talking about godzilla or kong
pig i would have put pig up there it's
97 i think certified fresh but other
than that when i take a look at this
list kyle i i see the only things that
really feel like
it feels like the power of the dog is
going to win and then everything else is
just looking for votes is that how you
see it or do you think it's a little
tighter i think it's a little tighter i
think the power of the dog is almost
certainly going to win best director
and we have seen in recent years that
the academy is
totally fine with splitting director and
picture they didn't used to be that used
to be a really rare thing but these days
they kind of like to spread the wealth
and i think if jane campion is really
locked in for director they could go
with something that is a little bit more
crowd-pleasing for uh picture which is
usually what they respond to you know i
don't think that's a done deal i think
that when you look at what got nominated
power of the dog got literally every
nomination it had hoped to get which the
other films can't say so you would think
okay well it has the strongest profile
going in but i really do think anything
could happen i agree i do think anything
could happen i will also say although
power of the dog is a netflix production
boat and has americans and other folks
in it and it's not necessarily what you
consider like the asian and south east
asian and the other parts of the academy
that's widened but i do think it does
have a very international feel with
benedict and jane and so i do think
international audiences
will migrate to it but those
international audiences are also the
reason why penelope i think got in for
best picture i think there's a
familiarity in the actors branch with
some of these i would say
more global names it's going to be
interesting to see which ones folks
resonate to
i'm more interested in coda code is
becoming quietly my one that i'm like
looking at i'm like apple's doing a lot
of things that i'm like
they really feel they got this here they
paid for this thing and they felt really
confident about it and they're doing
like a lot of very smart moves i think
to make it
viable for best picture that's just my
opinion what do you think about it well
i think it's very viable and supporting
actor um i think troy kotzer is is the
sort of heart of that movie as as the
father and coda um i think you know
there's essentially three knockout
endings in coda and he is the most
important person to all three yeah um
and i think that that category is very
fluid at the moment uh cody smith mcphee
from power of the dog won a lot of
critics prizes but honestly the academy
doesn't really go for like young actors
they love young actresses they love
themselves in ingenue but like a young
actor they're like um you've got time
you've let's get some like more wrinkles
let's make sure you're legit let's make
sure you're legit yeah and i do think
troy has is not only so wonderful in
that movie but has a kind of more
exciting story if he wins so
to me that's where
apple's efforts almost certainly could
find payoff but yeah i mean it's
interesting to see if if they can push
it all the way to picture this is the
reason why i want to like justify my
logic because we're all going to have to
monday morning quarterback whatever we
write down the sunday before or the
friday before this all goes down but um
i think about what is a lot of folks
second vote because i do think it's
going to be interesting to see i could
see a ton of people vote for power of
the dog i could see a ton of people vote
for west side story and a ton of people
vote for belfast but i still think a lot
of those folks second movie is coda
right and the way the voting works out
is where you could you could have a lot
of second places right you can have a
lot of second places that kind of push
you into into first because the first
place vote is so split that coda could
sneak in that way that's that's kind of
what i'm betting but also i will say
power of the dog equally has the same
argument for itself so anyway that's
just where i go and those are the two
that are actually at the top of our
rankings i think that
licorice pizza is a bit high in my
estimation yeah it's just
in general i don't dislike that movie i
have no
like ill will towards it i just feel
like it's a little bit high compared to
others i also think maybe king richard
is too i like that film
don't know if it really
hits everything that it's trying to
throw up like i don't know if it lands
aces every serve
serve up yeah i like where you're going
with that i i i really like king richard
a lot i i i mean you know i'm a big
sports fan like i've been following the
the williams sisters their entire career
and so it was kind of cool to get that
back story um and the performances were
amazing the movie that i look at here
that i would be rooting for for like an
upset victory would be belfast um just
because it is so cool i mean you look at
something like west side story and it's
such an amazing
production that steven spielberg was
able to pull off with a lot of magic in
it but i just look at the story of
belfast and particularly given the world
events going on right now the end oh my
god for those who stayed for those who
got out the way it says that it just
really really by the way if you don't
think focus features is thinking about a
way to co-opt this tastefully i don't
think you know oscar campaigning because
that's the first thing that's what they
do in the second phase of an oscar
campaign they have to make the argument
this is why this is the movie for right
now and uh and current events do
somewhat contextualize belfast in a
different way i do have to just put it
this way kyle looking over this list how
it has it ranked do you think rotten
tomatoes is wrong ranking these films
the way that they do
i think it's a pretty right on list
here's the thing
i don't think every
great movie needs to be perfect um i
have quibbles with some of these movies
to be honest with you the funny thing is
that i would probably recommend coda to
the most people but i think
personally that koda is a little high uh
i love troy kotzer in it and i think it
really brings it home but i think we're
all forgetting how kind of like
pat and
beamed in from planet cartoon the music
teacher scenes are and that's a big
subplot of that movie you know you
forget it because the
the final final scenes are so human but
i was kind of like white knuckling it
through those scenes like i don't know
about that i no comment as someone that
spent time with the cast but you know
no comment no comment is a comment
especially around award season you got
to read into all these no comments yeah
um so so you're saying you feel like
it's right we're right-ish maybe yeah i
i i don't i i think that's a pretty good
summation of just about how i would
order it i'd have code a little bit
lower no knock to be honest with you i
don't hate any of these movies sometimes
you get a best picture field where
there's one or two and you're like oh no
what are they doing there but even the
ones i like a little less i kind of
think
well for the most part think that they
deserve a placement in that and that
they are kind of like an accurate
depiction of what this year in film was
like and we should talk about it right
before we sort of break down some of the
more memorable moments of the two i
think this is a the best year possible
for the academy to be going back to 10
because i think the worst result of that
decision which i do think is right for
the academy and right for honoring the
best motion picture and now considering
that there are literally three times as
many films premiering a year as there
were 10 years ago with the at the
addition of streaming so
i really do think that having 10 is
great and it would really have been
awful if the 10th film this year was
something completely out of left field
there's a lot of folks that have
problems with don't look up but it is
not universally hated you know what i'm
saying despised or maybe i like this
outside of twitter maybe i yeah twitter
has its own feelings about a lot of
things but i i feel like don't look up i
i appreciate the effort and i appreciate
what it was trying to do it just that's
the movie that sticks out to me like a
sore thumb on this list just because
of the people involved of of the
director of the incredible cast that one
feels like it's almost like we have to
put this one in because we have 10 slots
and i don't think it has a chance of
winning and i don't really it just
doesn't really seem to stack up with the
i think that and nightmare alley are
properly placed i'll put it that way
because i'm like kyle i don't
necessarily hate any movies on this list
but i think nightmare alley and don't
look up belong way down there bringing
up the rear i'll play devil's advocate
but don't look up which is this is a
film that we will continue to reference
in the next few years sure
i don't hate don't look up i was just
i'm like
i i just said like i don't hate don't
look up i think don't look up is messy
in fact i remember i had heard a report
about like how it was being filmed and
it was edited like out all adam mckay
movies come together in the edit i think
every time that man is nominated for an
oscar his editor should be nominated as
well because all of his movies are made
in the edit they just take tons and tons
and tons of takes keep going it was a
bit messy it's a bit messy it was a bit
messy it was a bit rushed
probably could have been incubated
probably another six months and maybe
gotten something like the big short but
that's what i got on it yeah i
don't look up to just to me it doesn't
stack up with the rest of these movies
i'm not i it actually i thoroughly
enjoyed watching it and and again i love
what it's trying to do i don't think it
pulled that off magnificently because i
was really rooting for it too and i'm
still excited about what adam mckay does
with this project uh about the uh the
capital on january 6th i'm i'm excited
to see what he can do with that material
but
i mean i just don't see it as like a
best picture contender because when i
see a best picture nominee i want to
think it has at least a shot of winning
and when i look at the top eight of this
list i really feel like belfast could be
an upset i do i i feel like i i think
dune is just there maybe because they're
like hey sorry we didn't vote for you
danny even though you really deserved it
let's just put you in the the best
picture nominees instead but i i feel
like snubbed was actually my shock
everybody calls spielberg
everybody said it would be like
he or maybe even uh
kenneth branagh like i did but i was
shocked to see denny not on there what
about you yeah i mean i thought
spielberg might because uh west side
story seemed to be fading but i did i
didn't think brenna would get uh snubbed
you know belfast is his own story it's
kind of hard to separate him from it if
you like the movie and they clearly do i
mean honestly i i don't think belfast
winning best picture would be an upset
right now i'd be almost kind of tempted
to say that's where it's going to go
i think that if if it comes down to a
battle of the sort of you know smaller
sized crowd pleasers which would be coda
and belfast that belfast has a little
bit of an edge with the academy because
it's considered more artful
i think it's important to note that um
you know
there are certain movies that twitter
doesn't like
um in fact
again listen i'm not i'm not out there
trying to like
be uh
standing don't look up that's not my
vibe but i do think
the discrepancy between uh its uh
critic score and its audience score has
a little bit to do with everybody with
so many of the critics on twitter kind
of like seeing what the vibe was
uh and kind of all kind of landing in
the same place yeah it's 56 percent
rotten uh on the tomato meter then 78 of
the audience course that is that's like
a mark it's not quite a man-on-fire
situation but that's like that that's a
market improvement yeah i don't disagree
uh let's go ahead and talk about some of
the best moments from the year because
you know like any countdown list we have
to make sure we hit multiple categories
i have favorite moments from a lot of
these films but i think
i really um this is so funny i really
have to say everlasting love with jamie
and katrina was like a thing for me it
really was it really was i saw that very
late at night at telluride i was kind of
sleepy
but give me a good nostalgist song that
brings me back to like dirty dancing
type stuff like i think i've watched to
dirty dancing too many times not to love
everything that scene was doing kyle
what about you i loved all the bradley
cooper's stuff and licorice pizza and
here's the funny thing
if there was one movie i would boot from
this best picture lineup it would
probably be nightmare alley which i
don't think is an entirely successful
movie
i think it's way too lush and expensive
lush and expensive looking for a movie
that's supposed to be seedy you know
like if your circus looks like it costs
50 million dollars to stage but it's
supposed to be this you know uh den of
iniquity then i'm not really buying it
it's a little too over designed that
said that ending scene is fantastic uh
and that's one of the scenes that has
definitely stuck with me amongst this
best picture lineup oh man
that
that scene i was just thinking back i
saw that for the first time at new york
film festival when it premiered and it's
it's a pretty much exact almost beat per
beat from the original version but
seeing bradley cooper do it because
bradley cooper is so hollywood you know
what i mean i i don't think it was at
the new york film festival right wasn't
it there wasn't no no it wasn't the new
york film festival it was the screening
was at the tully hall apologies i'm like
honestly the only time i'm at the tully
hall in new york for new york film
festival i just happened to be there
when they were doing it but yeah it was
a new york film festival it was uh just
at the tully hall but anyway folks
they're literally getting their film
festivals confused
that's how many they attend
and honestly that is not hard to do
like
come on we i literally like when did i
see you last you have to just go back to
the last event uh but
he was so glossy like bradley cooper has
like got very movie star appeal and
that's what he plays when he's playing
the the mentalist in in those scenes and
so to then see somebody like that maybe
look like bradley cooper be that down on
it i thought was very interesting you
know i love to see people fall from
grace uh we've already talked about some
some of these as far as who and when and
such but
so snubs and surprises from that morning
because i still to this day we'll mark
that down as one of the strangest oscar
mornings i can recall you know to be
honest with you i thought tragedy
macbeth would do better it has a pretty
unimpeachable oscar pedigree directed by
joel cohn like denzel washington and
francis mcdormand are the stars and it's
based on shakespeare incredible looking
like you know i thought that was the
stuff and i i thought that movie was
great
it's just that when the dust settled and
i looked around nobody was really there
with me i don't know it didn't really
connect uh certainly denzel is in and a
lot of the tech stuff but i thought that
would be kind of a no-brainer
i i wasn't surprised but i was really
sort of disappointed that nothing came
outside of independent spirit for red
rocket i'm not surprised by it but i
still to this day
i am much more about what did this
person do given their
experience what they were asked to do
and like denzel doing shakespeare he
started doing a fellow 45 years ago as
impressive as that is this has been part
of who this man is for as long as he's
been an actor but the think of the guy
from scary movie four giving one of the
most incredibly disarming and
charismatic performances of a literal
sociopathic borderland like
narcissist
it's just so
i don't know man i i i still look at
that movie it's just like this complete
act of audience subversion i know you
are not as much of a fan no i like red
right oh you did oh i thought you didn't
like it as much a lot of people had
problems with the subject matter i
thought like you it's it's hard to root
for the guy but that's the brilliant
part the movie makes you root for him i
don't have to root for anybody i just
have to find him interesting that's my
rule of thumb when it comes to uh
unlikable protagonists oh that's good
everybody listening pin that that's a
that's a good it's a good quote to watch
movies going forward but jacqueline i
just i i think it's a tough line to draw
as far as like well denzel's been doing
this for so long i i i always hated that
carl malone won the mvp in a season when
michael jordan was playing basketball
just because it's like we're just tired
of it's like of course michael's great
it's like he's the best player he should
get the mvp so
i i feel like denzel earned it when i
woke up that morning by the way jaclyn's
the first person i think of when i wake
up on oscar nominations morning because
i don't text you i don't i just i send
you a note around 2 p.m and i'm just
like hey i'm here if you want to talk
that's it and then i go on my merry way
uh nicholas cage obviously i was hoping
he'd get nominated for pig
because that was just such a great
performance i also thought ruth nego was
going to be like a shoe-in for passing
because she's great in it and i would
that was the one that left even more so
the nicholas cage because it was a
stacked field in in best actor i mean
they're all look there's a lot of talent
out there but ruth nego was the one that
i was just
like i had to read the nominations again
cause i thought i just missed it yeah
that's that's brutal for me that was my
favorite performance of last year i i
wrote about it a lot in the times i felt
a little guilty because i also said they
should nominate jesse buckley that's one
i didn't think would ever happen jesse
buckley for the lost daughter i started
to think ruth negan might be safe
but i think that film deserved more and
and maybe there was only so much room uh
for you know all the movies that netflix
was pushing not that they didn't push it
but they also had another movie uh like
passing that was the directorial debut
of an actress very female fronted you
know with uh with actress and supporting
actress contenders and i think
ultimately the lost daughter ended up
getting the lion's share of buzz there
it did and what's really interesting
with it too
the maggie gyllenhaal
is very it's so interesting it's very
homogeneous
it's approachable in some ways with
maggie gyllenhaal as homogenous no the
movie the movie's makeup is somewhat
homogeneous as far as the makeup of the
folks you want to just say white people
i'm
it's white people in greece and you know
or italy and like you know whatever the
other the other performance i'll just
throw out there real quick is uh is jude
hill is deserving of something in
in belfast
that kid was just transcendental i don't
like children as you know jacqueline and
he just i just fell in love as soon as
as soon as he's on screen he's great
what did you think about him kyle i
think that when it came to the belfast
nominations
there was probably a lack of clarity
about what category a lot of those
people were supposed to be in um you
know uh the the two evidently supporting
performances both got nominated for
supporting and then everybody else
probably got a whole bunch of votes in
different categories that uh that kind
of wrecked their chances yeah that i'd
actually believe that that is the truth
as well and the confusion by the way on
the clarification on who is competing
what i think owes to the international
contingency as well because the films
are not marketed the same way out there
as far as like getting access to it
there's not as much fyc and so i just
don't know how connected they are to oh
i liked the belfast movie she's
competing for supporting actress well i
do like the spiciness of pushing back
against the you know sometimes very
craven cynical
um
categories that people get pushed in
sometimes a very evidently lead
performance is pushed and supporting for
all sorts of political reasons and
sometimes vice versa um and i do like it
when uh you know the academy's like no
we're just going to vote for them where
we want to vote for them and that's just
how it's going to be i mean sometimes
that's a little bit nuts and you get a
situation like with judas and the black
messiah where both of those men were
nominated in supporting because i don't
think there was clarity about who was
supposed to go where um but sometimes
they you know they right or wrong which
is kate winslet for the reader she was
being positioned as supporting because
she had a lead role in her then
husband's movie reservation
or a revolutionary road
and the academy said no you're the lead
uh that's where we're voting for you and
she ended up winning and that's where
she ended up winning yeah which i
thought was so funny as well let's go
ahead really quickly here because kyle i
know you have to get out of here fairly
soon but the fans are gonna be a bigger
part of this award ceremony for a bunch
of reasons uh they started it
nominations morning and previewed their
hand by having you know regular folks
and the tick tockers of the world coming
in and announcing the nominations and
they then announced
oscar fan favorite which is a sort of
back door to what they had previously
done
the popular vote oscar
and
it's a thing
i don't know
it's a thing i can't argue with that
it's a way to crown a movie that
everybody loves but this is like how
they avoid a dark knight controversy in
the future because the dark knight was
like worthy of being nominated right but
even even if you love a comic book movie
that may not be worthy of being in the
top ten you still want to give it some
recognition it to me it just feels like
the oscars are tired of getting yelled
at and so they're like look we'll give
spider-man something congratulations you
had three spider people show up here's
your here's your fan favorite burger
king crown well i think that's how they
hoped it would go i think they thought
well yeah of course everybody's
obviously going to vote for spider-man
it's the biggest film of the year but if
you peruse that hashtag it is
cinderella uh the amazon musical it is
uh army of the dead the zack snyder fan
base going hard for there's
a johnny depp movie that nobody saw but
that his you know uh remaining
contingent to fans are voting for these
are some of the most quickly forgotten
films of the year not spider-man and
i i think that this has the potential to
hilariously blow up in their faces it
does but i have a feeling it won't
like i don't know this for sure
because we haven't but like the next
twitter spaces or whatever they're gonna
let us know
and their site has already said that
like that's not it because they have two
things they have cheer moments yeah and
they have fan favorite and a lot of
these folks that are programming this
stuff or or trying to be whatever aren't
voting correctly so they're like giving
a cheer moment
on fan favorite and vice versa like
they're not doing what they need to do
to say i'm voting for the right way and
so it's actually the numbers are not
cinderella i'm pretty sure it's
spider-man's the number one now well i
think spider-man using the hashtag it
ain't but we'll see if they're a little
too embarrassed by those results when
they throw out some hanging chad ballots
look at you just putting all kinds of
implications to that i am not i think
the folks surprise price cooper house
price waterhouse
yeah are they handling that or is
somebody else you're not giving out an
actual oscar so i know how i feel about
this jacqueline i feel it i feel it was
complete i i think the whole
land uh moon uh moonlight thing was
completely on purpose i think it was to
drive up ratings for the next year and i
will die on that hill well you can die
on that hill but that dude lost his job
so
right now i think we've kind of said it
but just last sort of thoughts
kyle what do you think is going to win
picture
yep gosh you know i'm just gonna go with
the simple
one which is belfast i i do kind of
think that um there will be a split this
year um
but i'll be really curious to see
what ends up winning the producer's
guild award uh yes not that they always
match and sometimes recently they have
provocatively mismatched but yeah i i do
think that campion is such a lock that
it almost makes power of the dog less of
a lock for picture
yeah and see i think
brenna might be a lock on screenplay but
well usually to win picture you gotta
win screenplay it's very rare that you
don't and if you don't
you know
sometimes that happens uh uh and it
happens because of some really spicy
screenplays or a movie that doesn't feel
as motivated by its screenplay yeah and
i honestly think that
licorice pizza is not the type of film
that's going to topple belfast's stuff
in screenplay no yeah i really don't but
a lot of people are saying you know ptas
do ptas do but i'm just like i just
don't feel that yeah i don't know if the
academy does either i thought the movie
was going to do a little bit better i
mean it's it's not an uh
an unsubstantial thing that he made it
into the director race too you know
to get picture and director very few
films did obviously but um but virtually
nothing else you know the screenplay
sure but where were some of the actors
where was some of the other stuff i i
don't know that they feel this is the
movie absolutely mark what about you
what do you think is gonna win
i was prepared to just say the power of
the dog but now kyle's really swaying me
towards my heart yeah kyle was trying to
show me the way home here to belfast and
and you just sound like an oscar
campaign ad now yeah
because i believe the the uh
the narrative they've been going with in
their phase two oscar campaigning is
vote with your heart
uh
a very uh not so subtle slam against uh
the more maybe cerebral power of the dog
right true yeah by the way that is the
philosophy of of
donna langley one of the first things
she said to me when i interviewed her
once was she knew that green she knew
that donald trump from universal yeah
universal chair
chairman she's still chairman uh
universal chairman donna langley said
the reason why green book won is because
people loved it and they didn't care
what anybody thought and awesome
because and oscar voters vote for what
they love yeah it is that simple um and
you know i mean i love power of the dog
but i have talked to people who did not
you know who were not heart engaged by
it yes so i mean it's definitely a film
that moves you but it's not necessarily
something that tugs at your heart
strength i don't think it is definitely
a film that moves you you know i've
talked to people who are not moved um i
i love it and i think it got even better
the second time i watched it but it is a
more cerebral intellectual movie and
sometimes
most of the time oscar voters do vote
with their heart yeah i heard some i i
felt some some emotional ting just
watching it i have heard from people
that uh that they just thought it was
boring they thought it was slow but
um but i mean also you know you also
hear from people that belfast it's in
black and white so they can't watch it
i'm going i'm going belfast um because
guy's making me
you literally witnessed kyle make me
force me into a decision and i'm
thrilled that it's the one that i wanted
to say anyway but i was i wasn't brave
enough i wasn't brave enough to start
we'll see i'll be i'll be curious what
happens with the um screen actors guild
uh outstanding cast award but it is
important to note that like screen
actors guild and it's sag-aftra and
after has a whole lot of people that are
kind of
you know it has uh radio journalists
weathermen tick talkers so what they end
up going for might not be completely
reflective of the somewhat more
refined taste of the academy kyle the
reason why you're here on top of talking
oscars though is to tell us about this
incredible thing that you created
that i'm not going to say i literally
it was so funny i think i i mentioned it
to you like that should be a book and
you're like actually is that the i did
say that to you i think and you had
already started talking about making it
a book yeah so
this book about the making of mad max
fury road that i just wrote is somewhat
uh inspired and spun out of a much
smaller oral history that i did for the
new york times in may 2020 and yeah i
mean it was a really successful article
in the times and you said uh jacqueline
and you know other colleagues of mine
like manola darga said this should be
could be a book and you know when people
say that to you um or at least to me i'm
like okay
how does that happen though
you know i'd never written a book before
uh it seemed like a daunting endeavor
given that i have an incredibly
full-time job as it is um but you know i
kind of backed my way into it uh there
were incredible stories that just you
know
simply didn't fit into that times piece
and i knew that there would be more the
more people i talked to there's an
incredibly long credit scroll at the end
of that movie and every single one of
those people have fascinating stories
because it just was a shoot like none
other it's one of the craziest longest
wildest most difficult shoots in
hollywood history um and it produced a
masterpiece so i i knew that there was a
a lot of meat on that bone and
unfortunately you know once i got
together a book proposal uh there was a
lot of publishing interest in it and
here we are today i love it
it's an absolute must-read even if
you're not high on mad max fury road
necessarily i am but even if you're not
blood sweat and chrome the wild and true
story of mad max fury road so i heard
about this book and i didn't realize i
didn't connect the dots that you were
our guest on the show and then also this
book because i was doing morning radio
promoting my shows at the comedy store
and we were talking movies and about
this book that had come out that was
talking about charlize theron and and
tom hardy and their their their i guess
fishing on set there is somewhat of
relationship fractured early and i was
like oh yeah i mean i remember hearing
about that but i want to check out this
book you're the guy that wrote it
how but how can you just contextualize
was it just pure hatred was it venomous
was it just hey i just want to be in my
own character space what was the source
of the friction i really do think it's a
clash in approaches um you know
charles is an extremely by the book
actress uh she shows up right on time
she does exactly what you need her to do
and she does it you know astonishingly
well she can knock out something like
you know that take where furiosa falls
to her knees in the desert and screams
on the first take uh if you ask her to
do just about anything she'll she'll do
it tom hardy is not like that tom hardy
is somebody who kind of fails toward the
truth he as he will say you know he
experiments relentlessly and he will is
willing to humiliate himself in takes uh
in order to get to
something that feels wild but right so
that can take a while and so can he
honestly he does not he's not known for
his punctuality um and i think for
somebody like charlize who's very
professional who's out there in the
desert who's a little bit um
anxious about how this movie is going to
turn out and also has just adopted her
first child and probably wants to go out
there do a great job and go home it was
not uh the sort of
working relationship
that she would have preferred um and you
know he
a lot of people did not get along a lot
of people who worked on that movie
did not
know whether they were making you know
the biggest bomb of their lives or or
what turned out to be you know probably
one of the most lasting credits of all
of these people's resumes it's it's a
scary thing making a movie you know
especially if you're like
when you see these people not getting
along or you think to yourself
does george miller really know what he's
doing he hasn't made a live action movie
in ages his last two films were happy
feet and happy feet too you know does he
really know how to make like an action
movie that
our superhero weaned audience is gonna
respond to you know
people were terrified i was gonna say
too and i i get it because the thing
that the book is a testament to is it is
a minor miracle to make a bad movie like
even if you bring in every stakeholder
craftsmanship you have an incredible
vision a bulletproof script a studio
willing to do everything everyone can
come together and really have an earnest
desire to make an incredible film and
give you the worst movie you've ever
seen yeah that is happens so often than
not and then there's movies like this
where everyone hated each other there
are people calling their agents daily
like get me out of here
nobody enjoyed it it was traumatic and
stressful and they hated their existence
and it goes on to win six oscars
to be fair to be fair
many people who worked on it did enjoy
it and consider it the most creatively
gratifying experience of their lives but
there is an almost equal amount of
people who can't watch the movie because
it just
like you know the feelings of of anxiety
and
trauma in some cases are still really
fresh uh it's a tricky thing but yeah
you know i mean mark was saying earlier
that you don't have to be the biggest
mad max fan to read this book and i
think that's true i think that if you're
i mean obviously it's gonna help uh if
you wanna know about how they made this
movie because it is the sort of movie
you watch and you're like how the hell
did they make it
but i think if you're interested in how
they make any movie it's kind of a great
story uh you know for george miller to
have had this vision that he was
basically carrying around for two
decades and to have so many people say
you can't do this we'll shut it down
uh this won't work
and for all this you know kind of act of
god all these act of god obstacles to be
thrown in his path it's astonishing to
me that he still could keep the faith
and keep his torch burning and not just
say you know what
yeah we probably shouldn't do this i
mean it got shut down countless times
and he still had this faith in his
vision it was playing on a loop in his
head he knew how good it was
but he couldn't always make other people
see it until that movie came out yeah
jacqueline i feel like if you're one of
those people that believes in signs and
like the universe is trying to tell you
something everyone would have given up
on this movie multiple times this is
this is the universe telling you hey
don't make this movie and just and just
the belief that no we can do something
great and everybody willing to buy into
a 78 year old man on tatooine making a
movie it's j i mean again it's it's
astounding to watch that movie if if you
if i told you everybody was so copacetic
and just and it was such a great vibe on
set you'd still be astonished that movie
came out if there was a podcast that i
spent 20 years trying to get made and
everybody was like no i would have
abandoned ship on that ages ago let
alone this gigantic production that you
know capsized incredibly multiple times
it's it's a really crazy thing and it
yeah i think it makes you mull what kind
of temperament directors have and these
sorts of storytellers and what do they
have to have what kinds of spines of
steel do they have to have to get these
things over the finish line yeah again
it's you i always tell people when
you're making a movie it's essentially
like you're building a tiny city for
three months
that has to have an ecosystem
and it's a dictatorship
and they built this city in the desert
you know with nothing around so it was
they were living in that world and they
took great pains to make that world feel
as real as possible the stunt men were
living as war boys you know everybody
was living it and when you're out there
and you're on those vehicles that are
built for real that are moving for real
and the war boys are throwing spears at
you for real like it feels real you
don't have to do a lot of acting but
what you what you can't do is do a lot
of um decompressing a lot of pulling
yourself away from that world because
you're in it whether you like it or not
yeah i get it you know jack
this is why this book is so important to
me is that eventually you got to step
back a little bit because we love
talking movies on this show and it's fun
it's fun to dog bad movies and to praise
movies that we think were unfairly
maligned but at the end of the day it's
hard to make a movie yeah i don't want
any part of it so i i applaud i'm sorry
don't look up i apologize with your
pizza i hope you win all of the awards
you're you're great job well done love
it this is not what i wanted out of this
this was not my intention i promise
um let me say this uh kyle again uh
blood sweat and chrome the wild and true
story of mad max fury road is available
wherever fine books are sold online and
in person
uh thank you sir for being here where
can folks find you and anything i didn't
mention already uh i work for the new
york times you can find my column the
projectionist and the times online every
wednesday and in print every thursday
i'm also on twitter at kyle buchanan
awesome well i will see you in a q a or
reception soon sir or in a cool suit at
the sacramento i guess yeah well i don't
know are you doing produce we'll see
this is why we gotta go cause there's
another event before then yeah i want
picks i want pics of the suit oh yeah
definite picks definite picks all right
thank you sir
it was so great to chat with kyle please
guys also follow him on instagram i'm
not kidding about his uh suit game
done and done i'm very excited to see
this you know you gotta we're not
competing but i i like to know who else
is out there and what they're wearing so
i i make notes i i i take care of how i
appear in public occasionally the glow
up is real mark i see how you're doing
mark is approaching his 40s like this is
where to get flirty and that note though
[Laughter]
mean you're not wrong you're not wrong i
don't want to give him any chance to
comment on the fact that i just said
that he's trying to do 40 and flirty all
right guys
we still are taking submissions i have
to keep begging you we want to do the
hook episode we want to talk about rufio
we want to talk about glenn close having
a beard you have to send us this listen
our our overlords will not let us do it
without you like you have to do it your
stuff
audio video send it send in a clip of
why you feel the way you do about hook
to rt is wrong at rottentomatoes.com now
you got me whispering dustin hoffman is
captain hook bob hoskins says whoever it
was it's me i mean yeah no glitch goes
in that
glenn close is in that movie did you
know that mr showdown no but she used to
be married to my brother's guitar player
uh teacher
um years and years and years ago so how
about that did you know that jacqueline
oh my god all right that's it for us
this week we'll see y'all next time on
rotten tomatoes is wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you